Yeah, economy may come back in 2009, maybe
in 10, maybe in 11. That's not for me the
most important issue because it will come
back some day, today, tomorrow, or the day
after. But the issue is come back where. That's
my issue. Do we go back to the same normal
situation, quote unquote normal situation
that we were in before the crisis? When the
crisis is over we go back to that? Or we never
try to go back to that, we create a new normal
situation which is quite different then what
we have been going through. So that's the
one that I'm concerned with. The worst of
the crisis is the best of the opportunity
to change things. So to me this is the most
exciting pillar. To design the whole structure,
to design the things so that we can achieve
goals that we have set for our self. Creating
a new kind of world where people won't prevent
poor people who would be dejected from the
banking system that with the diseases, so
that we can move in that direction. The one
that the normal situation is coming from,
it didn't assure us. So it's good that they
created disguises. It gives us option now
to move out. Like for example the financial
system, so that all people are included in
the financial system. It's an inclusive financial
system. Not just exclusive club or privileged
people. We create new kinds of businesses.
Not only just money making businesses which
we have now, which makes us look like we are
some kind of money making machines. All we
do, all our life, make money. We're not money
making machines. We are human beings. We are
much bigger than money making machines. We
should be doing businesses to change the world.
So I talk about social business, how to include
social business in god frame world. We can
eliminate all of the problem that we created
in the past and create a new world. A world
without poverty, a world that exists without
hunger. Then we can make it. That's the normal
thing we should be working for an this is
the time to work for it. Thank you.